[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Taylor's
up next in Milwaukee Taylor welcome to
the
show hey how's it going guys great how
are you you're a little muff speak
directly in your phone for me a little
muffled is that better
perfect okay um so my fiance and I have
been struggling to pay off a little bit
of our credit card debt and I was
thinking the other night she works she
makes about 14 1450 a month take home
and she's paying we're paying $1,200 a
month in daycare um and so I thought to
myself why and we do do instacart um and
and door Dash and stuff on the side um
and I thought to myself why don't you
just quit your job put your twoe notice
in she's starting Cosmetology School in
the spring anyway so she's going to have
to be leaving her job why don't you quit
your job um and just do instacart door
Dash uh stuff like that uh fulltime um
with with our son staying at home more
with him uh and it's kind of funny I was
listening to guys a show a couple days
ago and I kind of feel like a little
desperate right now um and I picked up
something that stuck with me and it said
that when you're feeling desperate
you're gonna make a you're gonna be
stupid you're gonna make a stupid Choice
yes good call man so I thought man you
know maybe I could get on here and talk
to you guys and see how you guys feel
about this what do you feel desperate
about brother just so
we're current well
so listen to the show we've been paying
off we've been throwing all of our extra
pennies um at our credit cards too we
have just over 20 about 20 $23,000 in
debt um and we want to take care of it
because we want to buy a house so we've
been throwing all of our extra pennies
at it well I had to pay for books um for
my school I'm uh apprentice electrician
ibw and books came do so I went to pay
for my books and I thought I was adding
my credit card payment but I paid the
whole thing so that was a couple weeks
ago and so the last couple weeks we've
been kind
of literally living paycheck to paycheck
working out of a negative bank account
trying to catch up because we totally
did not expect that because then a
couple days later her our payment for
daycare um glitched and it double paid
that week so we paid out like $1,500
extra that we were not expecting that
week and so we're finally just that was
a couple weeks ago we're finally just
tomorrow you know she gets paid uh we
won't be working out of a negative
account we can get back on track you
know working at her debt um she just got
into a car accident Friday so which it
might help it wasn't her it wasn't her
fault someone pulled out in front of her
um so in a roundabout way we might not
have to pay her car loan anymore you
know and we'll just buy a beater car and
because God I don't want to pay I don't
want uh another car so 23,000 total
between the car loan and the credit
cards
no I'm not including that car alone into
this if we include that it's up over 40
but I don't think we're GNA have to I
think yeah I think eliminated my income
right now is400 a month um take home um
we I work a lot of overtime with my job
uh and it's temporarily permanent over
time I guess because with
being those are opposite
with overtime you're bringing up 2400 a
month no no no with overtime it's like
3,300 a
month and it's that's consistent for I
know but that's 500 extra dollars right
no I'm sorry 33900 extra dollars but I
wanted to use I I don't want to count on
that overtime because at any point it
could get eliminated right here okay
you've got you've got money chaos but
let me just cut right to it dude
underneath that you've got other chaos
what
well so a couple years ago we wanted to
buy we really wanted to buy a house so
we thought we could move into my parents
house and save up some money uh well
that didn't work Co hit and this hit and
we got Frugal with the money and it just
it just underneath that what's
underneath
that um here's what you sound like to me
okay you sound like a dad you got one
kid or two kids two two
kids is this woman your
wife um no we're engaged we've we've
been engaged for about eight years
why we I don't know we just have so when
we hold wait
we we have time to go through the whole
thing here's what it sounds like yeah
yeah yeah yeah you sound like a guy who
is fraying at the edges in a way that
makes me makes me nervous for you the
money is symptomatic of a life of a guy
playing whack-a-mole with his
life yeah can I I'm going to ask you a
hard question you don't have to answer
it are you using right
now um I I drink no yes here's how I
know that the way you are living your
body was not designed to handle the
wack-a-mole stress you put on it and you
have to have something to shut that
system
down either you got to have something to
speed up that system to keep up with it
or you got to have something to shut it
down yeah I'm I'm a I'm a very anxious
person am
yes what you need my man is to uh you
have to have a plan but you got to have
something beneath all this dude let me
ask you what are you running
from failure I guess yes why what are
you scared of man you have a woman who
loves you you got two healthy
kids yeah I mean honestly this might
sound kind of crazy but I've always been
commitment I'm afraid of commitment I've
always been really good at everything I
do but I can't ever just stick with one
thing
okay but when you get lasered in on
something I bet you're freaking amazing
aren't you I'm enjoying my career right
now yeah that's right I am but are you
the kind of guy that's gonna get
certified and get a great job and six
months later you're going to be like oh
look over
here um no okay I can't I can't so
here's the deal 33 I don't want to start
over again I love I love what I do I
really do that's amazing that's
amazing you are I need you I want you to
do something crazy when we get off this
call and it's going to sound insane okay
I want you to make a fist and I want you
to put it right in the middle of your
chest and I want you to walk into your
bathroom and shut the door and say these
words out loud I love this
guy and I want you to stare yourself in
the
eyes and my I'd be willing to bet money
that that's going to be hard for you to
do because right now you have a woman
telling you I love you so much I'll I
will play your little commitment
gymnastics even though we're together
for eight years because she loves you
that much and you got two kids who love
you got parents who are like dude move
on in you have a boss that's like do we
want you so bad around here we're going
to give you extra time cuz we need you
and your skill set and your character
around here the only person I hear in
your life that doesn't believe in you is
you and that has to stop today you got
two little boys you got two little kids
looking up to you
man okay I just called an electrician
and spent an ungodly amount of money you
know what I looked at that guy and I
said I said I trust you to take care of
my family cuz you have a skill set I
don't have please help and he came in he
said I got you that's what you do for
guys like me yeah every day I do that
but you you have to address the drinking
and you have to address the
anxiety and you have to address this
pretend I'm not getting married because
I don't like commitment but I'm with the
same person I've built a family in a
home but sort of with this woman marry
her and be done with that so your body
can
rest right and then we'll give you a
plan on the money we'll give you a plan
on the money man just got to follow the
plan okay is that I mean that sound good
it does yeah Taylor I don't think the
solution here is man if she just stays
home our problems are over you're just
trading one problem for another wack
whacko and it's not going to get you out
of the money mess it's not going to be a
big dent in the financial hole you guys
have created but you got to get serious
about this if she can get her income up
that will help the problem we're going
to hook you up listen I'm going to send
you building the non- anxious life my
new book I want you to follow it the
second thing is I'm going to send you
every dollar the best money app for
youall two to use together for a year
for free I'm going to send you the FPU
lessons for free but y'all got to do
them as a couple and make some
commitments and I want you to send me a
wedding invitation in the next 30 days
game on my brother I'll go with you John
it'll be fun